[Music]
keeping tabs on your apps and dealing
with errors can involve multiple tools
from multiple vendors this is far from
ideal and you really want all the tools
you need in one place stackdriver
monitoring provides visibility into the
performance uptime and overall health of
cloud powered applications stack driver
collects metrics events and metadata
from Google cloud platform Amazon Web
Services hosted uptime probes
application instrumentation and a
variety of common application components
including Cassandra Ingenix Apache web
server and many others stock driver
ingest that data and generates insights
via dashboards charts and alerts stack
driver alerting helps you collaborate by
integrating the slack pager Duty HipChat
campfire and more this hands-on lab
shows you how to monitor a Google
compute engine virtual machine instance
with stack driver you'll also install
monitoring and logging agents for your
VM which collects more information from
your instance which could include
metrics and logs from third-party apps
by the end of the lab you'll have
successfully monitored a virtual machine
and check the logs it generated next up
on our quest is cloud functions
QuickStart console
[Music]